[Music]
today's question comes from kathy in
arizona she says my daughter just got
married and her husband loves your show
and is budgeting according to your plan
for new couples who are starting out and
getting to know each other it's hard to
be on a tight budget with no extra money
for date nights or even a yearly
vacation with both of them working
full-time there needs to be something to
look forward to besides just paying the
bills shouldn't your plan be modified a
bit to include adequate funds for these
activities as they get to know each
other both personally and financially
that makes me laugh that's good kathy
wow i don't know what plan she read
your plan is to have no extra money
right that's the plan i know and love
[Laughter]
honey you need to leave your grown kids
alone and let them run their own lives
you interfering mother-in-law
what book did she read
oh
okay no we don't have money for date
nights in there when you're trying to
get out of debt
no we don't have money for vacations in
there when they're trying to get out of
debt and th this poor little couple
newly married will survive that they'll
make it a promise bob and they'll get to
know each other just fine because they
ain't got anything to do except sit and
look at each other so it's gonna work
out just fine i love that you said as
they get to know each other financially
yeah that's very interesting so here
here is what you do need to guard
against i'm making fun of you kathy
because you need to be made fun of but
um
but the the thing you do need to guard
against here that you are right about i
will take your side on this is if he is
being a control freak clamping down and
your daughter doesn't have a vote
in this your daughter needs to speak up
because what we do teach is that both of
them have a vote
but we do teach to sacrifice to win to
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else and if they
both
are committed to getting out of debt and
they're going to sacrifice to win the
way we teach it is not going to harm
their little tender relationship as a
matter of fact it will draw them closer
together because unlike their other
married friends who are so freaking
snowflake that they're all they worry
about being nurtured instead they're
actually sacrificing to hit a goal
together and that draws people closer
together than snowflaking in the same
room
that's uh that sums it up well here's
what i'm saying
their financial situation isn't clear
here we don't know if they're investing
the fact that she said they're on a
tight budget makes me think they're
probably in baby step two they're
probably broke he wants to get them out
of debt so they can go on vacation and
not come home with the vacation on the
credit card for the rest of their life
and mommy is worried about her little
princess they're newlyweds they're fine
i know they don't need to go anywhere
and you know but seriously they it's
okay if they have no our budget does not
say you cannot enjoy your life it does
say
that you should tighten up everything
and not have a bunch of fluff in your
budget
uh in order to accomplish your financial
goals which is get out of debt and it is
worth the sacrifice and no it will not
damage their relationship beyond harm
and you know what creates that margin
for all that fun stuff getting out of
debt it's amazing how that works the
reason an old fart like me laughs at
something like this
is because i remember when i got broke
when i got married i was so broke i
couldn't pay attention
and i can guarantee you neither one of
our mothers gave a crap
about our little relationship so dave
should take sharon on vacation
my little daughter is not gonna no her
mother's like you you people only get
your butt and gear and work that would
have been both of our mothers i mean
they would have had none of this i mean
but but it's a different thing now so
it's a little bit of a helicopter
parent kathy that's what we're hearing
if kathy cares so much just send them on
vacation no gift it to him
no
don't interfere
she's already clearly these grown people
be grown people
you quit helicoptering
um that's what i read here now if kathy
if i'm being mean to you and you get
your little feelings hurt i understand
she'll call in or email yeah she'll send
me an email but it's okay i'll still
love you and i'm just gonna make fun of
you for being a helicopter mom and
you're sweet you love your daughter but
you need to let her toughen up a little
bit it's not gonna kill her she's not
gonna lose her relationship her
husband's not gonna hate her she's not
gonna hate her husband because they
can't go out on a date night sharon i
didn't even know what a date night was
after we got married prior to getting
married we had date nights but after
getting married i mean we were married
five years before this whole date night
thing that's true yeah you're supposed
to go out on a date on tuesday night
back then you were going steady right
that's what it was no we were just
married it's like the whole thing was a
date you know it wasn't like we had to
go out somewhere into a restaurant to
prove it so but it's just but that's
olfart stuff so the times have changed
get with it back before their ears ended
what began with an art before ought 22
you know oh my gosh but yeah oh yeah
such a boomer showing your age yes
definitely yeah i i just but you know
but there is something about new york
i did i went to podcast with mark mike
rowe this morning dirty jobs and mike
and i are like brothers from a different
mother on this stuff and so we were we
talked for an hour the podcast went on
way too long just two bucks
i think i messed up his podcast but um
uh i don't know when it airs but y'all
be listening for it he and i were having
a lot of fun and they happened to record
it too so but we were just talking about
entitlement and snowflakes and
and i was bragging on the millennial
generation because i always do you know
that george i have a good reputation for
bragging on them the ones you meet and
hear at least but the uh well i meet
them everywhere they work on our team
there's a bunch of them and they work
hard they're the portions of the
millennial generation are amazing
portions of mart but we love the
portions that are and they make great
you know i have great marriages we see
them in here doing debt-free screams and
all kinds of things
but the ones that are entitled
snowflakes the where they come from
is this right here
and that parenting is what leads to that
this right here this is who has a 31
year old living in their basement
that's really good at nintendo
really good at call of duty
and nothing else
and uh because you know when we
washing his own clothes it's just too
much to ask you know so making up your
own bed oh my gosh it's a lot of work
yeah so i'm making fun of you kathy but
i tell you what if if it's not you it's
somebody else out there like you that
i'm making fun of you pointing to a
bigger problem there you go thank you
very much it's not about this it's a
macro discussion and you opened up the
can of worms
so yeah that's the thing so no um
no we shouldn't modify our plan
i hadn't modified it in 30 years
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else it's in the
bible
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness